hot like butter speaking of butter
award-winning chef and restaurateur
david chang is out with the new cookbook
today his first in more than a decade
it's called cooking at home and how i
learned to stop worrying about recipes
chang teamed up with priya krishna a new
york times food reporter who was already
a best-selling author the pair joined
jamie yukas in the kitchen where the
professional chef revealed his go-to
shortcut their microwave
yum
david chang has mastered the kitchens of
some of the most celebrated restaurants
in the world but these days
[Music]
he's learning to be a seasoned cook at
home i don't think i've ever made a
recipe the same way more than once
it's a bit of unfamiliar territory for
the six-time james beard award winner
he opened momofuku noodle bar in new
york city in 2004 and has since rolled
out restaurants books a podcast and tv
shows to create his empire i don't want
to cook i want to see this robot out
cook me
now alongside his co-author priya
krishna he's trying to let go of the
rigid rules he adheres to in his
restaurants i actually had never cooked
at home
i mean i know that sounds ridiculous
i wasn't a young kid that tried to get
in the culinary profession my dad worked
in the restaurant industry and he worked
his entire life to make sure i would
never work in the restaurant industry
and i got into cooking after college and
i never thought about cooking at home
what are we serving today but as the
pandemic persisted
chang like many of us found himself
dusting off the pots and pans in his
home kitchen
so good
the beauty of cooking is sort of
treating recipes like guidelines and not
like the gospel truth it's super
important for people to know that
you know authentic cooking or making
something exactly from a recipe is that
never actually going to happen
changing krishna's book is a road map to
working with what's in the fridge and
learning to season
krishna was raised on her mom's indian
cuisine in a home where meat was never
served her best seller indianish
highlights her culture's colorful dishes
chang's parents immigrated from korea in
the 1960's wow their taste could not be
more different but together they created
a book full of flavor how do you know
this is done and your chicken isn't
overcooked
i just know
we had so many like hours long
conversations of me just being like just
tell me how long to cook the brisket for
and dave being like i can't tell you it
just depends it was
a difficult moment in the creation of
the book
the book is also full of tips like use
your freezer as a pantry you'd be
surprised at what you can chuck in your
freezer you can grate cheddar cheese
throw it in your freezer there's very
little i won't put my freezer now i
basically become my mom because my
freezer is a nightmare things that i was
embarrassed about growing up was like oh
my god i don't want anyone to see what's
in a freezer because
it's like a
taxidermy experience like i don't know
why what
i open the fridge and i'm like oh man i
got like 20 minutes i got to make
something i'm like what do i do when
chang is short on time he speeds things
up in a microwave with a passion that
might surprise you it is a machine from
the future here in present day and
people are like no i don't want to use
it i'm like
want their packages delivered faster
they want to see things on demand but
they want to cook something as slow as
possible
and i have a hard time grasping that
you can't get things crunchy and golden
brown but you can start in the microwave
and then finish it in a pan
on this day they're whipping up chicken
coconut curry
and caccio a pepe
if you do it in a blender it's foolproof
it really is born out of total laziness
so good so good
but a peek at chang's instagram reveals
delicious and nutritious food isn't just
the key to his heart it's who he's
making it for his wife grace and son
hugo hi peppa
i'm eating tacos you're gonna eat
chocolate you love your family you love
cooking i think as a man though too to
show your devotion to your family is a
big thing i never thought i'd be able to
experience the ability to love something
more than myself
it's caused me to realize just how
selfish i was and how i would live my
life and
cooking at home made me understand why i
should be cooking to begin with i love
it now i can't imagine any other way
what do you think hugo good
i'm still learning how to communicate to
my family
the easiest way for me to do it is
through food it's a delicious way yes it
is
dinner's ready thanks hugo for cbs
mornings i'm jamie yucas in los angeles
hungry do you cook you don't cook you
already asked me this during the break i
eat to serve yeah but i'm asking for
them
i don't know if you know that they're
five yeah
i do what i have to do
clearly you cook i love to cook yeah i i
find that taking over the kitchen is is
one of the best uses of my time and you
just said when you're in the kitchen
you're in charge yeah in fact that's one
of the issues sometimes my wife wants to
be in charge of the cooking and i we get
kind of elbow each other out of the way
i'm like out out yeah that's exactly how
it goes one cook at a time yeah i make
too much of a mess yeah we love each
other though all right we'll be right
back
[Music]